we're here with the one and only jeff
goldblum
and jeff the internet is chock full of
random jeff goldblum awesomeness and we
found a bunch of stuff that you can buy
online and we wanted you to review each
one and if you don't mind would you rate
it in a one through five system but one
to five gold blooms yes ma'am i i will
one to five gold
[Applause]
okay look there's a coloring book with
you can i can i pick this up yeah is
this going to disturb anything what the
heck is this so this is an adult
coloring book oh i'm a frightened it's
not an adult in that i was going to say
i'm not sure okay well i like it so far
oh no this is already five gold blooms i
give it five gold
[Applause]
you and i after this show we should get
some crayons and just busy ourselves for
hours and hours and hours look we've got
the color pack hey there we go i like it
all right this is actually very good
come over here i've not seen this i've
never held it and by the way this is not
my merch i don't get any money from this
i don't know it and nor do i have any
it's nice to know that people love you
though and are making merch with you uh
yeah nice look at this
now
what do you see well thank goodness what
you see is look you don't see me on the
inside as you're showering you know
you're not being peered at but yeah take
a look think that it would be fun look
at this get out
what the heck is going on
sorry nothing you see here nothing to
see here
[Applause]
that's very good how many gold blooms
five of course okay
[Applause]
i feel like
that gets ten gold blue i've seen i've
seen pictures of it but i've never i've
never seen it what the heck okay oh my
gosh this one has a lot of festive
festive flair it's you in a king's hat
you know what oh king head yeah a son
around you
and you're being jazzy a crown right
right or otherwise known as a king hat
yeah king head is that a king hat it
looks like a king hat
or better known as a crown yes what's
that word yes crown crown crown
how many goldblums
well let me see let me look at it first
of all i like it you know that's a nice
thing i like the that might be the pull
out king reference uh um five absolutely
five that's pretty good okay
it's not wound so it's not going around
what is this this
thank you i really
i'm surprised
i didn't expect it to feel like this yes
it's it's like a chenille it's very soft
what is that is that um
is that flannel or some kind of i think
it's chenille
it's a very cozy cozy jeffy very cozy uh
isn't shin wait a minute isn't chenille
it's soft but with the ribbing
chenille yeah you can rip this a little
bit um but it's very good look oh yeah
yeah you could you could have lots of
many
lots of fun with that how many gold
blooms for this many gold blooms yeah
yeah
just golden i love you
thank you so much
the world according to jess goldblum is
on disney class we'll be watching for
the next jurassic world and we'll be
watching you with love and pom-poms and
i'll do dances for you i'm with you for
the rest of my life you can dance for me
any time
[Music]